So a new girl transfers into Rebecca's high school, an all-girls school. And it took a little while for everybody to figure her out because she transferred in from public school. Actually, from one of the best public schools in the city. But still, in their eyes---
有个新女孩转到了丽贝卡的高中，那是一所全女子学校。大家花了一点时间才弄清楚她的底细，因为她是公立学校转来的。其实，她转自城里最好的公立学校之一。但即便如此，在她们眼中——
She like had a lot of background. And so when she came here, people thought she's nothing. She's another--
她好像有很多背景。所以当她来这里时，人们觉得她什么也不是。她又是那种……
Public school kid? Oh, so she's just like--
公立学校的孩子？哦，所以她就像是……
She's ghetto.
她是贫民窟出来的。
She's ghetto? She's ghetto, meaning she's from public school?
贫民窟出来的？她是贫民窟出来的，意思是她来自公立学校？
No. Just the style.
不。只是风格问题。
Does she dress ghetto?
她打扮得很贫民窟风吗？
At first. When she first came there. Ghetto hoochie mama.
一开始是。她刚来的时候。那副贫民窟浪荡女的打扮。
Ghetto hoochie mama. I have to admit I did not know exactly what she meant by that. So helpfully, Rebecca searched her brain for another phrase to explain it.
贫民窟浪荡女。我得承认，我不太明白她这话具体是什么意思。于是丽贝卡很热心地在脑子里搜寻了另一个词来解释。
Booty house girl. Do you what house music is?
“翘臀舞派对”女孩。你知道什么是浩室音乐（House music）吗？
Yeah, of course.
知道，当然知道。
She was the kind of girl who all into booty house music.
她就是那种沉迷于“翘臀浩室”音乐的女孩。
Fact is, there are so many ways of being a teenage girl, and you can switch from one to another Like one friend of Rebecca's who started high school with blond hair, blue eyes.
事实上，十几岁女孩的生活方式有太多种了，你可以从一种切换到另一种。比如丽贝卡的一个朋友，刚上高中时金发碧眼。
She started with the alternative, preppy girls. Gap clothes. Straight, Gap, Banana Republic khakis, the crewneck sweaters.
她一开始走的是另类预科生路线。盖普（Gap）服装。直筒裤，盖普的卡其裤，香蕉共和国（Banana Republic）的卡其裤，还有圆领毛衣。
How'd she talk when she was alternative?
那她走另类路线时怎么说话的？
With no accent, no inflection on anything. She was just kind of like, yeah, dude. Yeah. That year, that was freshman year. And then she went to the Spanish group after, the Latinas. And she dressed in big, gold hoop earrings and real dark lipstick, like almost black. And the real thick eyeliner. And then she started saying-- she'll be talking to you and she says but. She wouldn't say but anymore, she'd say pero. That's Spanish. And she'll go mira, mira. You know, mean look.
没有口音，没有任何语调起伏。她就是那种，嘿，伙计（dude）。嘿。那年是高一。后来她加入了西班牙裔群体，拉丁女孩那一拨。她戴着大金圆耳环，涂着深得发黑的口红。还有那种很粗的眼线。然后她开始说——她跟你说话时会用“pero”（但是）。她不再说“but”了，而是说“pero”。那是西班牙语。她还会说“mira，mira”。你知道，就是“看”的意思。
Look, look, look. Right.
看，看，看。没错。
She got more and more into it where she'd say instead of "look at that fine guy," "oh, look at that papi over there." That was all of sophomore year. And then, junior year she was kind of getting like-- well, we called it ghetto style. Because all of a sudden, she was dressing with big, baggy pants, windbreakers, Nike shirts, big gold chains. And if she wanted to tell you-- so she got excited. She'd get real excited.
她越陷越深，比如她不再说“看那个帅哥”，而是说“哦，看那边那个帅哥（papi）”。整个高二一年都是这样。到了高三，她开始变得——好吧，我们称之为贫民窟风格。因为突然间，她开始穿大号肥大的裤子、防风夹克、耐克衬衫、戴粗金项链。如果她想告诉你——她变得很兴奋。她会变得非常兴奋。
And OK, she came up to me one day and she's, oh, girl, we was driving in the car. We saw this guy. He was fine. And he looked my way and I was like, what's up, baby.
好的，有一天她跑来跟我说，哦，女孩，我们当时在车里。我们看到了那个家伙。他真帅。他看向我这边，我就说，嘿，宝贝（what's up, baby）。
Wow.
哇。
And she got real into it though, smacking her lips and [MAKES LIP SMACKING SOUND]. She gets hyper. And she's slamming her hands.
她入戏真的很深，还会吧唧嘴，发出那种声音。她变得很亢奋。还会拍手。
So that was her black year basically?
所以那基本上是她的“黑人年”？
I think.
我想是吧。
Now senior year, that girl is a Clueless girl. Clueless. Meaning she acts and dresses like the characters in the movie and the TV show Clueless. Stacked shoes, polyester bellbottoms, retro '70s style.
现在高四了，那女孩成了《独领风骚》（Clueless）里的那种女孩。独领风骚。意思是她的行为举止和着装都像电影和电视剧《独领风骚》里的角色。厚底鞋、涤纶喇叭裤、复古的70年代风格。
It's hard to imagine many boys changing style this quickly, this willfully, this many times. It is very, very girl. Transforming yourself head to toe every year because you can. And because you're expected to be that obsessed with how you look.
很难想象有哪个男生会这么快、这么刻意、这么多次地改变风格。这非常、非常“女孩”。从头到脚每年都重塑自己，因为你能这样做。而且因为人们期望你对自己的外表如此着迷。
So Rebecca, we're thinking about calling this week's show, I Enjoy Being a Girl, Sort Of. And I just want to ask, do you have any thoughts on that theme?
所以丽贝卡，我们正在考虑把这周的节目命名为《我喜欢做个女孩，差不多》。我想问问，你对这个主题有什么想法？
Sort of? Well, I love being a girl.
差不多？嗯，我喜欢做个女孩。
How so?
怎么说？
Because we get to the fun things.
因为我们能做些有趣的事情。
The fun things being?
有趣的事情是指？
I mean, we can do whatever we want with our faces, with our clothes, with our hair. And well also because girls don't get as much pressure from things like gangs and all that stuff that guys do. We don't have to be hard and try to be, like macho. But we could if we want to. And since all the equal rights have come up, we can do whatever. Like way more options than back in the day. It's perfect.
我是说，我们可以在脸上、衣服上、头发上随心所欲。而且，女孩们不像男生那样承受来自帮派之类的压力。我们不需要表现得强硬，不需要假装硬汉。但如果想的话，我们也做得到。自从平权运动兴起后，我们能做任何事。比以前的选择多多了。这很完美。
It's perfect?
很完美？
Well, no, no. OK, it's not perfect. But it's getting there.
嗯，不，不。好吧，还不完美。但正在变得完美。
And it's better than being a guy?
那比做个男人更好吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Well, today on our program, enjoying being a girl, sort of, and sort of not.
好吧，今天我们的节目主题是：享受做个女孩，差不多，或者说不完全是。
Act One, Fatty Suit. David Sedaris explains how one girl sidestepped her father's wish that she be thin and pretty and focus on getting a man through a technique that was almost like a kind of industrial sabotage.
第一幕，肥胖套装。大卫·塞达里斯（David Sedaris）讲述了一个女孩如何绕过她父亲希望她瘦削漂亮并以此吸引男人的愿望，她采用了一种近乎工业破坏的方法。
Act Two, How to Be a Man. Writer Sarah Miller attends a class in New York City that teaches women how to walk and talk and act like men.
第二幕，如何做一个男人。作家萨拉·米勒（Sarah Miller）参加了纽约市的一门课程，教女性如何像男人一样走路、说话和行事。
Act Three, Strength in Numbers. Six women, a van, a 12 hour drive to Mississippi that starts in the middle of the night and ends in a casino in a cotton field.
第三幕，人多力量大。六个女人，一辆面包车，一场从深夜开始、在棉田里的赌场结束的12小时车程。
Act Four, Taking Sisterhood One Step further. A happily married polygamist wife explains how having eight women married to one man is the ultimate feminist lifestyle. From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass, stay with us.
第四幕，将姐妹情谊更进一步。一位幸福的一夫多妻制妻子解释了为什么八个女人嫁给一个男人是终极的女性主义生活方式。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台和国际公共广播电台，这里是《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass），请继续收听。
Act One, Fatty Suit. David Sedaris has this parable of the pressures on modern women and how one woman, his sister, responded.
第一幕，肥胖套装。大卫·塞达里斯讲述了一个关于现代女性压力以及他姐姐如何应对的寓言。
My father called me late one recent Sunday evening, excited with the news that my sister, Amy, was scheduled to appear in a magazine article on young, New York women.
最近一个周日的深夜，我父亲打来电话，兴奋地告诉我，我姐姐艾米（Amy）将出现在一本关于纽约年轻女性的杂志文章中。
Can you imagine, he asked. My God, put a camera in front of that girl and she'll shine like a diamond! Between the single men and the job opportunities, her phone is going to be ringing right off the hook!
你能想象吗？他问道。天哪，把摄像机对准那个女孩，她就会像钻石一样闪耀！无论是单身男士还是工作机会，她的电话都会响个不停！
My father has always placed a great deal of importance on his daughter's physical beauty. It is to him, their greatest asset, and he monitors their appearance with an almost freakish intensity. Because it was always assumed that we would go to college, my brother and I were free to grow as plump and ugly as we liked. I might wander freely through the house drinking pancake batter from a plastic bucket, but the moment one of my sisters overspilled her bikini, our father was right there to mix his metaphors.
我父亲一直非常看重女儿的身体美。对他来说，这是她们最大的资产，他以近乎变态的强度监控着她们的外表。因为我们一直被认为是要上大学的，我和我哥哥可以自由地长得又胖又丑。我可以随意在屋子里游荡，从塑料桶里喝着煎饼面糊，但一旦我的姐妹中有人比基尼勒出了赘肉，我父亲就会立刻出现，混合使用他的比喻。
Jesus, Flossy, what are we running here, a dairy farm? Look at you, you're the size of a tank. Two few more pounds and you won't be able to cross state lines without a trucking license.
天哪，弗洛西（Flossy），我们这是在干什么，开奶牛场吗？看看你，你像辆坦克那么大。再胖几磅，你没货车驾驶证就别想跨州了。
Three of my sisters responded to this pressure by losing themselves, however briefly, to drugs and alcohol. The one exception is my sister, Amy, who for as long as I can remember has chosen to lose herself in others.
我的三个姐妹通过吸毒和酗酒来应对这种压力，尽管只是短暂地迷失了自己。唯一的例外是我姐姐艾米，据我记事起，她就选择在别人身上迷失自己。
For Amy, school was dedicated solely to the study or her teachers. She meticulously charted the reputation of their shoes and blouses and was quick to pinpoint their mannerisms. Practicing alone in the basement, she would pace before her king-sized blackboard in full costume.
对艾米来说，上学就是为了研究老师。她一丝不苟地记录下老师们穿的鞋子和衬衫的声誉，并很快指出他们的言行举止。独自在地下室练习时，她会全副武装地在巨大的黑板前踱步。
Her imaginary classroom was a forum where the teachers ignored the lesson plan, preferring instead to discuss their elaborate home lives, which most often involved the bedridden mother forced to take oxygen through a tank. My sister turned that same eye on the adults my parents knew from the neighborhood and country club. Choosing from her box of wigs and castoff dresses, she would prepare herself a false cocktail and sat at the rec room bar, mastering their slurred inflections.
她虚构的课堂是一个论坛，老师们忽略了教学计划，更喜欢讨论他们复杂的家庭生活，通常涉及卧床不起、被迫靠氧气瓶维持生命的母亲。我姐姐用同样的眼光审视我父母在邻里和乡村俱乐部认识的成年人。她从假发和旧衣服的盒子里挑选行头，给自己准备了一杯虚假的鸡尾酒，坐在娱乐室的吧台前，掌握他们醉酒后的语调。
She was great as Flow Wagner and Eleanor Kelleher. But vocally, her best impersonation was of Penny Midland, a stylish, 50-year-old woman who work part-time at an art gallery my parents used to visit on a regular basis. Wearing a white page boy wig and one of my mother's better caftans, Amy began calling my father at the office.
她模仿弗洛·瓦格纳（Flow Wagner）和埃莉诺·凯勒赫（Eleanor Kelleher）简直绝了。但从声音上来说，她模仿得最好的是佩妮·米德兰（Penny Midland），一位时尚的50岁女性，曾在父母经常光顾的一家艺术画廊兼职。戴着白色的男童头假发，穿着母亲的一件较好的卡夫坦长袍，艾米开始给父亲的办公室打电话。
Lou, Penny Midland here. How the hell are you? An awkward conversationalist, our father would fidget before saying, Penny. Well, what do you know? Gosh it's good be hear your voice.
卢（Lou），我是佩妮·米德兰。你怎么样啊？父亲是个不善言辞的人，他会局促不安，然后说，佩妮。哇，什么风把你吹来了？天哪，能听到你的声音真好。
The first few times she called, Amy discussed gallery business. But little by little, she began complaining about her husband, a Westinghouse executive named Van.
最初几次通话，艾米聊的是画廊的生意。但渐渐地，她开始抱怨她的丈夫，一位名叫凡（Van）的西屋电气公司高管。
I want out, she'd say. It isn't that I don't care for him as a friend, but at this point in my life I don't know that I can stay married to a man who, well, a man who likes boys. I don't know how else to say it. The man likes boys and that's the way it is.
我想离开他，她说。并不是我不关心他这个朋友，但在我人生的这个阶段，我不知道能否继续嫁给一个，嗯，一个喜欢男人的男人。我不知道该怎么说。那个男人喜欢男人，就是这样。
Our father offered comfort with such standard noncommittal phrases as, "I guess it takes two to tango," or "You hang in there, baby."
我父亲用一些标准的、不置可否的话语提供安慰，比如“我想这得两厢情愿”，或者“你坚持住，宝贝”。
Oh, Lou, it just feels so good to talk to someone who really understands.
哦，卢，能和真正理解的人说话真是太好了。
I walked into the kitchen late one afternoon and came upon my 12-year-old sister propositioning her father.
一天深夜，我走进厨房，撞见12岁的姐姐正在向父亲求爱。
I was thinking that maybe you and I could get together some time, just for laughs. Unless we felt like taking it to another level.
我在想，也许你和我可以在某个时候聚聚，纯属娱乐。除非我们想把关系推向另一个层面。
Amy studied her reflection in the oven door, brushing the white bangs away from her forehead with her heavily jeweled fingers.
艾米对着烤箱门里的倒影端详着，用满是珠宝的手指把白色的刘海从额头上拨开。
All I'm saying is that I find you to be a very attractive man. Is that a crime?
我只是说，我觉得你是个非常有魅力的男人。这是犯罪吗？
This was what my mother meant when she accused people of playing a dangerous game. Were my father to accept Penny's offer, Amy would have known him as a philanderer and wondered who else he might have slept with. Everything he'd ever said would be called into question and scanned for possible sexual content. Was that really a business trip, or had he snuck off to Myrtle Beach with one of the Stravidies twins?
这就是我母亲指责别人玩危险游戏时的意思。如果父亲接受了佩妮的提议，艾米就会知道他是个好色之徒，并怀疑他还和谁睡过。他所说的一切都会受到质疑，并被扫描寻找可能的性暗示。那真的是商务旅行吗，还是他偷偷溜到默特尔比奇和斯特拉维迪斯（Stravidies）双胞胎中的一个幽会了？
It is to his credit that our father was such a gentleman. Stammering that he was very flattered to be asked, he let Penny down as gently as possible. He offered to set her up with some available bachelors he knew from his office at IBM and told my sister to take care of herself. Adding that she was a very special woman who deserved to be happy.
值得称赞的是，我父亲是一位绅士。他结结巴巴地说很荣幸被邀请，并尽可能委婉地拒绝了佩妮。他主动提出要把她介绍给IBM办公室认识的一些单身汉，并告诉我姐姐要保重。还补充说她是一个非常特别的女性，理应幸福。
It was years before Amy admitted what she had done. They were relatively uneventful years for our family and I imagine, a very confusing period of time for poor Penny Midland, who was frequently visited at the art gallery by my father and any number of his divorced business associates.
多年后艾米才承认了她的所作所为。那对我们家来说是相对平淡的几年，我想，对可怜的佩妮·米德兰来说也是一段非常令人困惑的时期，因为我父亲和许多他离异的生意伙伴经常光顾那家艺术画廊。
Here's the gal I was telling you about, he'd say to Bob Sweetie or Tommy Lattermore. I think the two of you would make a dynamite couple. I swear to God. Maybe some night this week the two of you could slip away and maybe have a few drinks. Give it a try why don't you?
这就是我跟你提过的那位女士，他会对鲍勃·斯威蒂（Bob Sweetie）或汤米·拉特莫（Tommy Lattermore）说。我觉得你们俩会成为一对绝配。我发誓。也许这周哪天晚上你们俩可以溜出来喝几杯。试试看，为什么不呢？
The passage of time has not altered my father's obsessive attention to my sister's weight and appearance. And because of that, most of them keep their distance, checking in only by phone.
时间的流逝并没有改变我父亲对我姐姐体重和外表的痴迷。正因如此，她们中的大多数人与他保持距离，只通过电话联系。
Is it just my imagination, he'll ask, or has your voice gotten fatter? You sound chubby to me. Is everything OK?
是我产生幻觉了吗？他会问，还是你的声音变胖了？听起来很圆润。一切都好吗？
Because she has maintained her beautiful skin and youthful figure, Amy is my father's greatest treasure. She is by far, the most attractive member of our family. Yet she spent most of her life admiring skin diseases and praying for a hump.
因为她保持着美丽的皮肤和青春的身材，艾米是我父亲最大的财富。她是目前为止我们家最有吸引力的成员。然而，她一生大部分时间都在崇拜皮肤病，并祈求长个驼峰。
It's not fair that I can't grow a beard she'll say, gluing a pebble-sized wort to the side of her nose. Compliments are genuinely lost on her. She can't see any benefit to being herself and is constantly searching for what she considers a flattering disguise.
我不长胡子真不公平，她会说，在鼻梁上贴一个鹅卵石大小的疣。恭维话对她完全没用。她看不出做自己有什么好处，总是在寻找她认为令人奉承的伪装。
She's got all the neck braces and false teeth a person could want, and recently spent a good deal of money on a customized fatty suit she enjoys wearing beneath sweat pants as tight and uninviting as sausage casings.
她拥有一个人所能想要的所有颈托和假牙，最近还花了一大笔钱买了一套定制的肥胖套装，她喜欢穿在像香肠衣一样紧身且毫无吸引力的运动裤下面。
She couldn't afford the matching top and is reduced to waddling the streets much like two women fused together in some sort of a cruel experiment. From the waist up, she's slim and fit, chugging forward on legs the size of tree trunks and followed by a wide, dimpled bottom so thick she could sit on a knitting needle and never feel a thing.
她买不起配套的上衣，只能像两个在残酷实验中融合在一起的女人一样蹒跚街头。从腰部以上，她苗条又健美，但拖着两条树干一样粗的腿蹒跚前行，身后跟着一个巨大的、布满酒窝的屁股，厚到她坐在针尖上都感觉不到。
She wore it home last Christmas where our startled, heartbroken father met us at the airport. He managed to silence his disapproval on the short ride to the house, but the moment Amy stepped into the bathroom he turned to me shouting, what the hell has happened to her? Jesus Christ Almighty, this is tearing me apart. I'm in real pain here.
去年圣诞节她穿着它回家，我们那受惊且心碎的父亲在机场接我们。在回家的短途车程中，他压制住了自己的不满，但当艾米走进洗手间的那一刻，他转身对着我大喊：她到底怎么了？上帝啊，这简直要把我撕碎了。我真的很痛苦。
What?
什么？
Your sister, that's what. The girl's ass is the size of a beanbag chair. I thought you were supposed to be keeping an eye on her?
你姐姐，就是这样。那女孩的屁股大得像个懒人沙发。我以为你应该盯着她？
I begged him to lower his voice. Please dad, don't mention it in front of her. Amy's very sensitive about her-- you know.
我求他小声点。拜托爸爸，别在她面前提这个。艾米对她的——你知道的，很敏感。
Her what? Go ahead and say it. Her big fat ass. That's what she's ashamed of, and she should be. Christ Almighty, they could land choppers on ass like that.
她的什么？说出来啊。她那巨大的肥屁股。那是她羞愧的地方，也是她应该感到羞愧的地方。天哪，他们能在那样的屁股上降落直升机。
Oh, dad.
哦，爸爸。
Don't try to defend her, wise guy. She's a single woman and the clock is ticking away. How is she supposed to find a husband with an ass like that?
别为她辩护，聪明鬼。她是个单身女性，时间在流逝。她怎么能带着那样的屁股找到丈夫？
Well, I said, a lot of men like that.
嗯，我说，很多男人喜欢那样。
He looked at me with great pity and shook his head. What you don't know could fill a book.
他用极大的同情看着我，摇了摇头。你所不知道的能填满一本书。
My father composed himself when Amy re-entered the room, but the moment she opened the freezer door he acted as though she were tossing a lit match into the gas tank of his Porsche.
艾米回到房间时，父亲平复了心情，但当她打开冰箱门时，他的反应就像她往他保时捷的油箱里扔了一根点燃的火柴。
What in God's name are you doing? Look at you, you're killing yourself.
你在干什么？看看你，你在自杀。
Amy hugged a quart of ice cream to her chest and searched the drawers for a shovel-sized spoon.
艾米把一夸脱冰淇淋抱在胸前，在抽屉里寻找一把像铲子一样的勺子。
Your problem is that you're bored, my father said. You're bored and lonely and you're eating garbage to feel some kind of stinking void. I know what you're going through and believe me, you can lick this.
你的问题是你无聊，我父亲说。你无聊、孤独，你在吃垃圾来填补某种该死的空虚。我知道你在经历什么，相信我，你能克服的。
First of all, Amy said, I'm not bored. And besides that, all I've eaten today are a stack of pancakes, four donuts, a danish at the airport, and a couple of really small brownies on the plane. She kept it up until our father, his voice cracking with pain, offered to find her some professional help.
首先，艾米说，我不无聊。而且，我今天只吃了一堆煎饼、四个甜甜圈、在机场吃了一个丹麦酥，还有在飞机上吃了两个很小的布朗尼。她一直坚持到我父亲声音嘶哑地提出帮她寻求专业帮助。
I'm begging you to reach out before it's too late. We can do this together. There are programs and camps that specialize in this kind of thing. But first, you have to admit that you have a problem.
我求你在一切太迟之前向人寻求帮助。我们可以一起度过难关。有专门针对这种事情的项目和营地。但首先，你得承认你有问题。
When Amy rejected his offer, he attempted to set an example. Settling down to Christmas dinner, he pretended to be satisfied with nothing but a sliver of white meat accompanied by a single spear of broccoli. His athletic regime became theatric. That felt great, he'd say, finishing a round of sit-ups. Now I'll do some squat thrusts, a couple dozen pushups, and it's off for a satisfying run. Anyone want to join me? Amy?
当艾米拒绝了他的提议时，他试图树立榜样。在享用圣诞大餐时，他假装只吃一片白肉配一根西兰花就满足了。他的健身方案变得很有戏剧性。那感觉太棒了，他在完成一轮仰卧起坐后说。现在我要做一些深蹲推举，做几十个俯卧撑，然后去跑个满足的步。有人想加入我吗？艾米？
She kept to her fatty suit until her legs were chafed and pimpled. It was on the morning of our return flight when she revealed her joke and our father, bracing himself against the countertop, wept with the light. Ha-ha he laughed as though he were reading the words off a page, the way he's always done. Ha-ha-ha, you really had me going. Ha-ha. I knew you'd never let yourself go.
她一直穿着肥胖套装，直到双腿被磨得通红发痒。在返回航班的早晨，她揭开了这个玩笑，我父亲靠在柜台上，喜极而泣。哈哈，他笑着，就像在读纸上的文字一样，就像他一直做的那样。哈哈哈哈，你真的把我骗倒了。哈哈。我知道你永远不会让自己堕落的。
The fatty suit only reinvigorated him for the photo shoot he called about with such enthusiasm. She had me fooled for a minute there, but even with a fat ass, you can't disguise the fact that she's a beautiful person and that's what really matters. Do you happen to know if they're going to be hiring a professional hairstylist, someone who really knows what they're doing? I sure as hell hope so because her hair is awfully thin and someone needs to talk her into losing those bangs.
肥胖套装反而让他对那场他如此热情谈论的照片拍摄感到振奋。她骗了我一会儿，但即使有个大屁股，你也掩盖不了她是个美丽的人的事实，这才是最重要的。你知不知道他们会请专业的发型师，那种真正懂得自己在做什么的人吗？我真希望如此，因为她的头发太薄了，有人需要说服她剪掉那些刘海。
There's a lot I don't tell my father when he calls asking after Amy. He wouldn't understand that she has no interest in getting married and was in fact, quite happy to break up with her live-in boyfriend.
我父亲打电话询问艾米的情况时，我有很多事没告诉他。他不会明白她对结婚毫无兴趣，事实上，她很高兴和同居男友分手。
He was a pleasant, hardworking fellow, whom she replaced with a dwarf rabbit named Tattletale. Tattletale enjoys chewing electrical cords, and as a result my sister's phone is often out of order. But it doesn't seem to bother her that available men can't get through.
那是个讨人喜欢、勤奋的家伙，她换成了一只名叫“告密者”（Tattletale）的侏儒兔。Tattletale喜欢啃电线，结果我姐姐的电话经常打不通。但单身男士联系不上她，她似乎并不在意。
The last time she was asked out by a successful bachelor she paused for a few moments before saying, thanks for asking, but I'm really just not into white guys right now.
上次有个成功的单身汉约她出去时，她停顿了几秒钟说，谢谢你的邀请，但我现在对白人不太感兴趣。
This alone would have given my father an aneurysm. The clock is ticking, he says. If she waits much longer she'll be alone for the rest of her life.
光是这一点就足以让我父亲脑溢血了。时钟在滴答作响，他说。如果她再等下去，余生就得一个人过了。
This seems to suit Amy just fine. For the time being, she seems perfectly content with her rabbit and an imaginary boyfriend she has named Ricky. We'll be walking the streets of her West Village neighborhood, running errands, when she'll turn to me saying, Ricky gave me a bumper pool table for our one-month anniversary. I came home this afternoon and there it was parked beside the baby grand electric organ he gave me for President's Day.
这对艾米来说似乎正合适。目前，她对她的兔子和一个她取名为瑞奇（Ricky）的虚构男友感到非常满足。当我们走在西村街头办杂事时，她会转向我说，瑞奇给了我一张碰碰球桌，作为我们一个月的纪念日礼物。今天下午我回到家，它就停在总统日他送给我的电风琴旁边。
I didn't know you played pool, I'll say. When did you start? How did you learn?
我不知道你会打台球，我会说。你什么时候开始的？你怎么学的？
Oh, a few months ago. Ricky taught me how to play on our last flight to Korea.
哦，几个月前。上次去韩国的航班上瑞奇教我怎么打的。
You didn't tell me he was Korean?
你没告诉我他是韩国人？
Oh, she'll say, he's not. He just has a lot of friends there, so we go to Korea a lot. She carries on like this and after a while, Ricky seems not only real, but very likable.
哦，她说，他不是。他只是在那里有很多朋友，所以我们经常去韩国。她就这样继续说着，过了一会儿，瑞奇不仅显得真实，而且非常可爱。
Hey, my father will ask, what do you know about this Ricky person? Amy seems to think he's really something.
嘿，我父亲会问，你对这个叫瑞奇的人了解多少？艾米似乎觉得他真的很了不起。
What exactly has she told you? It's always best to ask what he's already heard. For all I know, Amy could have claimed that Ricky was a Navy SEAL, or the chief surgeon at a hospital specializing in diseases of the kidney or pancreas.
她到底跟你说了什么？最好的办法总是问他已经听说了什么。据我所知，艾米可能声称瑞奇是海豹突击队队员，或者是专门研究肾脏或胰腺疾病的医院的主治医师。
When my father called asking about the photo shoot, I feigned ignorance. I didn't tell him that at the scheduled time, my sister arrived at the studio with unwashed hair and took her place beside a half dozen women carefully dressed in flattering outfits. She waited while the others had their hair styled into the current fashion. One by one, their brows were trained while makeup artists made the most of their lips and cheek bones.
当我父亲打电话询问照片拍摄的事时，我假装不知情。我没告诉他，在预定的时间，姐姐顶着没洗的头发来到工作室，和半打精心打扮的女性并排站立。她等着别人做当前流行的发型。一个接一个，她们的眉毛被修饰，化妆师最大限度地凸显了她们的嘴唇和颧骨。
When called fourth to the styling table, Amy said only, I want to look like someone has beaten me up really, really bad. The makeup artist did a fine job. The black eyes and purple jaw were accentuated by a series of scratch marks on her forehead. Puss yellow pools surround her blistered nose and her swollen lips were fenced with mean rows of brackish stitches.
轮到她坐在化妆台前时，艾米只说了句，我想看起来像被人暴揍了一顿，真的很惨。化妆师做得很出色。黑眼圈和青紫的下巴被额头上一系列抓痕突显出来。化脓的黄色水泡围绕着她起泡的鼻子，肿胀的嘴唇被几行难看的青褐色缝线封住。
Amy was enchanted with her new look. Following the photo shoot, she wore her bruises to the dry cleaner and grocery store. Most people nervously looked away. But on the rare occasion someone asked what had happened, my sister smiled as brightly as possible saying, I'm in love. Can you believe it? I'm finally, totally in love. And you know what? It feels great.
艾米对她的新造型着迷了。照片拍摄后，她带着伤痕去了干洗店和杂货店。大多数人紧张地避开了目光。但偶尔有人问发生了什么事，我姐姐就会露出最灿烂的笑容说，我坠入爱河了。你敢相信吗？我终于、彻底坠入爱河了。你知道吗？感觉太棒了。
David Sedaris is the author most recently of, Dress Your Family in Corduroy and Denim, and editor of the collection, Children Playing Before a Statue of Hercules: An Anthology of Outstanding Stories. This story was originally written for Vogue magazine, which then rejected it without explanation. One Vogue employee speculated that perhaps it did not conform enough with Vogue's notions of feminine beauty.
大卫·塞达里斯是最近出版的《穿灯芯绒和牛仔布的家人》（Dress Your Family in Corduroy and Denim）的作者，也是《在赫拉克勒斯雕像前玩耍的儿童：杰出故事选集》（Children Playing Before a Statue of Hercules: An Anthology of Outstanding Stories）的主编。这个故事最初是为《时尚》（Vogue）杂志写的，但被该杂志拒绝，没有给出任何理由。一位《时尚》员工推测，这或许不太符合《时尚》对于女性美的定义。
David's sister Amy is among other things, a star of the TV show and someday to be released movie, Strangers with Candy.
大卫的姐姐艾米是电视剧以及即将上映的电影《陌生人与糖果》（Strangers with Candy）的主演。
[MUSIC- "I'M A WOMAN" BY PEGGY LEE]
[音乐- 佩吉·李（Peggy Lee）演唱的《我是个女人》]
Act Two, How To Be a Man. Well, one of the problems in doing a show like we're doing this week, a show made of different stories that seem to go together because they were all about, at some level, different ways of being a woman or a girl, is that you find yourself treading around all these broad generalizations about men and women that actually none of us really believe. But we figured, we came this far with this theme, we might as well head down the river into the heart of darkness of gender cliches. And playing the Martin Sheen role in our little gender apocalypse now will be Sarah Miller.
第二幕，如何做一个男人。好吧，在做我们这周这样的节目时，遇到的问题之一是，这档节目由不同的故事组成，它们之所以被放在一起，是因为它们在某种程度上都是关于做女人或女孩的不同方式，但你会发现自己在兜售那些关于男人和女人的宽泛概括，而实际上我们中没人真正相信这些。但我们想，既然在这个主题上走到了这一步，我们不妨顺流而下，深入性别陈词滥调的黑暗之心。在我们的性别版《现代启示录》中，萨拉·米勒将扮演马丁·辛（Martin Sheen）的角色。
Sarah Miller for a while, had the odd job of being a woman who wrote a sex column for men in a men's magazine, Details. That job seemed to consist mostly of correcting guys gross misperceptions about women. We sent her to a class we heard about in New York City run by a woman named Diane Tore. A class that tries to teach women how to dress and walk and talk like men. So it's kind of a reverse on her regular job.
萨拉·米勒有一段时间做着一份奇怪的工作：为男性杂志《Details》的男性读者撰写性专栏。那份工作似乎主要是纠正男人们对女性的严重误解。我们派她去纽约市参加一个据说是戴安·托尔（Diane Tore）开办的课程。这是一门试图教女性如何像男人一样穿衣、走路和说话的课程。所以这算是一种反向尝试。
Sarah Miller put on a loose fitting flannel shirt and tried to imagine transforming herself not just into any man, but into the kind of man who does not have a kind of ambiguous mix of traditionally male and female traits. She would become a guy's guy.
萨拉·米勒穿上一件宽松的法兰绒衬衫，试图想象将自己不仅仅变成任何男人，而是变成那种没有任何传统男女特征模糊混合的男人。她要成为一个彻头彻尾的“纯爷们”。
I have to admit the idea of the workshop made me anxious. Just before I went I told a friend that I was afraid I already seemed like a guy. I'm tall, I'm loud, I swear a lot. I told them I was afraid that Diane would say something to me like, God, you're a natural. And I would take this to mean, you are naturally coarse and masculine. And naturally, not at all pretty.
我得承认，这个工作坊的想法让我感到焦虑。就在我出发前，我告诉一位朋友，我担心自己看起来已经像个男人了。我长得高，声音大，还经常骂人。我告诉他们，我担心戴安会对我大喊大叫，比如，天哪，你是天生的。我会把这理解为：你天生粗俗且男性化。而且天生一点也不漂亮。
I shouldn't have worried. It turns out there's a whole world of gestures and attitudes between me in a flannel shirt and me being mistaken for a man. There's the proper way to walk, for example. Diane demonstrated.
我不该担心的。事实证明，在穿着法兰绒衬衫的我与被误认为是男人的我之间，有着一整个姿势和态度的世界。例如，走路有正确的方法。戴安做了演示。
Sense of resolution ownership. Sense that when I walk into this room, anything, anybody, could be mine. I could own anything and anybody, or everything, in this room. For that moment that my eyes rest there. So that sense of ownership is conveyed in the gaze.
决断力和主权感。当我走进这个房间时，感觉任何东西、任何人都可以是我的。我可以拥有这个房间里的任何东西、任何人，甚至一切。在我眼睛停留的那一刻。所以那种主权感是通过眼神传达的。
They're not afraid to take up the space or to own the space. Or to check things out. How's this place structured?
他们不害怕占据空间或拥有空间。或者去观察事物。这个地方是怎么构建的？
So when you walk you think you have a perimeter, a boundary of about three foot around you, OK? And this [UNINTELLIGIBLE], the way he walks, it's coming from the shoulders. The hips are tight and he goes side to side at the same time he goes forward. So it's like this 360 degrees moat around me, OK?
所以当你走路时，你要想你周围有一个大约三英尺的周长，一个边界，OK？这个[听不清]，他走路的方式，是从肩膀发力的。臀部很紧，他左右摇摆的同时也在向前。所以这就像我周围有一条360度的护城河，OK？
Then we gave it a try. I thought slumping was the quickest route to maleness, but when I looked around I saw the other stood ramrod straight. We examined each other for clues.
然后我们试了一下。我以为驼背是通往男性化的最快途径，但当我环顾四周时，我看到其他人站得笔直。我们互相检查对方的线索。
And maybe just introduce yourself to different people in the room. Just shake hands. Don't smile. Stop smiling.
也许只是向房间里的不同人做个自我介绍。握个手。别笑。停止微笑。
Smiling was the one thing none of us could seem to cut out. Diane had to remind us again and again. So as it became clear to me that I was not going to leave as a convincing man, I manufactured a goal for myself. I was here, I decided, to learn arrogance.
微笑是我们中没人能戒掉的一件事。戴安不得不一次又一次地提醒我们。所以当我很清楚自己不会以一个令人信服的男人的形象离开时，我为自己设立了一个目标。我决定，我是来学习傲慢的。
Yeah. So you want to cover the nipples first of all. Going to start wrapping from the bottom.
是的。所以首先你要盖住乳头。从底部开始缠绕。
An ACE bandage, my sisters, is the first tool you need on your path to gender liberation. Mine was double wide. It kept snapping out of my hands as I wrapped it around my chest.
姐妹们，弹性绷带是你走向性别解放的第一步。我的带子是双宽的。我缠绕在胸部时，它总是不停地从我手中滑落。
It's got to be quite tight. But not so tight that you can't breath. That's ridiculous. So remember, you're going to be wearing this the whole day and evening. So should be OK. All right, here we go.
必须缠得很紧。但不能紧到无法呼吸。那太荒谬了。所以记住，你全天都要戴着这个。所以应该没问题。好的，我们开始吧。
This was the actual song we were listening to as we wrapped our chest down. Diane had brought along a tape called "Frat Rock" to enhance that double X chromosome vibe we were all striving for.
这正是我们缠胸时听的实际歌曲。戴安带了一盘名为《兄弟摇滚》（Frat Rock）的磁带，以增强我们都在追求的那种双X染色体的氛围。
[MUSIC PLAYING - BAD COMPANY - CAN'T GET ENOUGH OF YOUR LOVE]
[播放音乐 - 坏公司乐队（Bad Company）的《Can't Get Enough of Your Love》]
My clothes, two big Levi's, a plaid flannel shirt, a Princeton t-shirt with Hebrew letters, all would have hung nicely on a guy's broad shoulders and slim hips. But I looked a little lumpy. My breasts had not disappeared so much as retreated under extreme duress to the middle of my chest. Two sad, misplaced lumps uncertain of their meaning. My whiskers were good, but my eyes-- Diane pointed this out about all of us-- retained the hopeful sweetness of femininity. And if I resembled anything, it was only some strange hybrid of a lumberjack, lady from Lady and the Tramp, and Marie Antoinette.
我的衣服，两条大码李维斯（Levi's），一件格子法兰绒衬衫，一件带希伯来字母的普林斯顿T恤，穿在男人的宽肩膀和细臀部上本来会很合身。但我看起来有点臃肿。我的乳房并没有消失，而是在巨大的压力下退缩到了胸口中间。两个悲伤、错位的肿块，不知道它们的含义。我的胡茬不错，但我的眼睛——戴安指出了我们所有人的这一点——依然保留着女性那充满希望的甜美。如果说我像什么的话，那只是伐木工、《小姐与流浪汉》里的女士和玛丽·安托瓦内特的奇怪混合体。
I made up a new identity. Now my name was Dan Rosen. I was a Brown dropout who worked at St. Mark's Bookshop. I stacked the [UNINTELLIGIBLE] readers. I bought Paul Auster novels on discount. My parents lived in Mt. Kisco and were lame. Brown was lame. I was lame.
我编造了一个新身份。现在我叫丹·罗森（Dan Rosen）。我是一个从布朗大学辍学、在圣马克书店工作的人。我堆放[听不清]读物。我打折购买保罗·奥斯特的小说。我父母住在基斯科山（Mt. Kisco），很逊。布朗大学很逊。我很逊。
I'm Dan. I'm Dan.
我是丹。我是丹。
The thing is that you are using the same [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
问题在于你在使用相同的[听不清]。
Hello, hello, hello.
你好，你好，你好。
--rhythm.
——节奏。
I'm Dan and my boobs hurt.
我是丹，我的胸部很疼。
As Dan I sat down for my eating lesson and I noticed that none of us were really winning any surprises in the realness department. Two of the girls had long hair tied back in ponytails. When you looked at them you had a split second to decide if they were women dressed up as men or the Allman Brothers, and it wasn't a tough call.
作为丹，我坐下来接受进食课程，我注意到我们中没人真正在“真实感”方面赢得任何奖项。其中两个女孩扎着马尾辫。当你看着她们时，你有一秒钟的时间决定她们是男扮女装还是奥尔曼兄弟乐队（Allman Brothers），这可不是个简单的决定。
One of them asked Diane how we should be sitting.
其中一个问戴安我们应该怎么坐。
With your legs open. Until you're taking as much space as possible.
双腿张开。直到你尽可能多地占据空间。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah, you see guys on diners. You sit next to them and they'll be in these little round seats. And their knees will be pushing right into your--
是啊，你在餐馆里看那些男人。你坐在他们旁边，他们会坐在那些小圆凳上。然后他们的膝盖会一直顶着你的——
On a subway.
在地铁上。
The subways as well.
地铁上也一样。
We could sit and eat with our legs as wide as we wanted, but we were not men. One of the Allman Brothers spent the meal nibbling her way through about half a piece of pita bread. Eating it with the slow deliberation of one not at peace with food. The other Allman Brother looked a little bit like a guy, but she had this way of nodding and saying, uh hmm when she listened and it gave her away.
我们可以双腿张开坐着吃饭，但我们不是男人。其中一个“奥尔曼兄弟”花了整顿饭的时间，一点点啃着半块皮塔饼。吃得慢条斯理，像个对食物感到不安的人。另一个“奥尔曼兄弟”看起来有点像个男人，但她那种点头说“嗯哼”听人说话的样子出卖了她。
Only Diane, dressed up as her alter ego, Dan King, looked like a guy. It was the eyes more than anything else. Her's were cool, detached. They assumed rather than asked. We were all too eager and naive looking. I said that we looked like little does tenderly eating grass and everyone laughed.
只有戴安，装扮成她的另一个自我——丹·金（Dan King），看起来像个男人。那主要还是眼神的原因。她的眼神很酷、很疏离。那是假定而不是询问。我们都看起来太渴望、太天真了。我说我们看起来像小鹿在温柔地吃草，大家都笑了。
When we finished eating, the place was a mess. Food, napkins, and take-out containers everywhere. No one wanted clean up. We sat in our men's clothes, staring at everything, not moving. I knew what we were thinking.
我们吃完后，那个地方一团糟。食物、餐巾纸和外卖盒到处都是。没人想清理。我们坐在男装里，盯着所有东西，一动不动。我知道我们在想什么。
So now we got to get some [BLEEP] bitches to clean this [BLEEP] up, huh?
所以现在我们得找几个[脏话]婊子来清理这堆[脏话]了吧，嗯？
Yeah.
是的。
My highest hope for the workshop once I realized I was in very little danger of actually resembling a man, was that I would have some great insight into the mystery of what makes men men and women women. But I think there's no mystery left. The train of gender is too familiar, full of places we visited way too many times.
一旦意识到我实际上几乎没有变成男人的危险，我对工作坊的最高期望就是能对男人之所以成为男人、女人之所以成为女人的谜团有一些伟大的见解。但我认为已经没有谜团了。性别的列车太熟悉了，到处都是我们去过太多次的地方。
Men are detached, unapologetic, unafraid to take up space. Women are conciliatory and self-effacing. Men gulp, women sip. I'm not sure there's anything Diane or anyone could say that would really surprise any of us.
男人疏离、不道歉、不怕占据空间。女人调解、自贬。男人大口吞咽，女人啜饮。我不确定戴安或任何人能说出什么真正让我们感到惊讶的话。
I did have one moment in the workshop where I was walking across the floor, shoulders hunched, lips in a scowl, where I felt what it must be like to Dan Rosen. College dropout, keeper of the magazine section. Is this it, I thought? Is this what it feels like to be a guy?
我在工作坊里确实有过一个时刻，我弯着肩膀，撇着嘴走过地板，那时我感觉到了成为丹·罗森是什么感觉。大学辍学生，杂志区管理员。就是这样吗，我想？这就是做个男人是什么感觉吗？
But I realized that what I felt-- useless, defensive, underachieving, bored, tragically adolescent-- was not about feeling like a guy, but about remembering what it felt like to be in my early 20s. What it felt like to be a failure. And I don't need to be in drag to tap into that.
但我意识到我所感受到的——无用、防御、表现不佳、无聊、悲剧性的青春期——与感觉像个男人无关，而是关于记住20岁出头的感觉。那种作为失败者的感觉。而且我不需要穿变装来感受这些。
As our graduation ceremony for the workshop, we wanted to go to a men's club to watch strippers. But it was a Sunday night in Giuliani's New York and we couldn't find a single one open. I was secretly relieved when we ended up at a restaurant in the West Village. Right there in the booth I surreptitiously unwrapped my chest. I ordered a Diet Coke and a salad.
作为工作坊的毕业典礼，我们本来想去一家男士俱乐部看脱衣舞。但那是朱利安尼统治下的纽约的一个周日晚上，我们一家也没找到。当我们最终在西村的一家餐馆落脚时，我暗自松了一口气。就在小隔间里，我悄悄解开了我的束胸。我点了一杯健怡可乐和一份沙拉。
Sarah Miller. These days she writes a column for Men's Health magazine. Her novel, Inside the Mind of Gideon Rayburn, is coming out this March.
萨拉·米勒。如今她为《男士健康》（Men's Health）杂志撰写专栏。她的小说《基甸·雷伯恩的内心世界》（Inside the Mind of Gideon Rayburn）将于今年三月出版。
Coming up, polygamy as feminist lifestyle. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，作为女性主义生活方式的一夫多妻制。一分钟后，我们的节目继续，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台。
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of writers and reporters and everyday people to come in and speak on that theme. Today on our program, I Enjoy Being a Girl, Sort Of.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，每周我们都会选择一个主题，邀请各种作家、记者和普通人来讨论这个主题。今天我们的节目是：《我喜欢做个女孩，差不多》。
In this second half of our program, we turned the stories of individual women and girls to stories of groups of women and girls. We have arrived at Act Three, Strength in Numbers.
在节目的下半部分，我们从个体女性和女孩的故事转向了群体女性和女孩的故事。我们来到了第三幕，人多力量大。
This is the story about one group of women. And I have to say that every woman working on this show at some point during this last week has expressed a little envy for the women in this group. And I think maybe the best way to start their story is with their road trip. Barbara, Jewel, Lynn, Tiny, Valerie, and Rosetta decided to leave the husbands and kids and grandkids behind and hit the road.
这是一个关于一个女性团体的故事。我必须说，本周在节目组工作的每一位女性，在某个时刻都对这个团体的成员表达了一点羡慕。我想开始她们故事的最好方式，也许就是她们的公路旅行。芭芭拉（Barbara）、朱厄尔（Jewel）、琳（Lynn）、泰妮（Tiny）、瓦莱丽（Valerie）和罗塞塔（Rosetta）决定撇下丈夫、孩子和孙辈，上路了。
I was the first pick up.
我是第一个被接上的。
And?
然后呢？
And they picked me up about 4 o'clock.
她们大约4点钟接的我。
4 o'clock in the morning?
凌晨4点？
4:00 AM. We arrived at the donut place and they were not open. They did not open til 7:00.
凌晨4点。我们到达甜甜圈店时，它们还没开门。要到7点才开门。
That is sad when you arrive at the donut place-- you were earlier then.
当你到达甜甜圈店时，那真是够惨的——你到得太早了。
They were not open.
它们没开门。
And they would not open to 7:00 on the dot.
而且它们非要到7点整才开门。
We're waiting on 6 o'clock, so we can go into the donut place.
我们在等6点钟，这样我们就能进甜甜圈店了。
I think [UNINTELLIGIBLE] in there.
我想[听不清]在里面。
We got three hens in the car planning on how we could go up to Rosewood hospital and sneak up in the room.
我们车上有三个“母鸡”（Hens），在商量怎么溜进罗斯伍德（Rosewood）医院，偷偷潜进房间。
So it's like 4:00 in the morning. Sometime between 4:00 and 6:00 in the morning on a Friday morning and you decide you're going to visit one of your friends, one the hens who's in the hospital before you hit the road.
所以大约是凌晨4点。在周五的凌晨4点到6点之间，你们决定在上路前去探望你们的一位朋友，那个也在住院的“母鸡”？
That was going to be a break in.
那是一次闯入。
Yeah, but you know I thought we'd kind of pose as doctors and we're coming to see [? Marilyn Jones. ?] There's a special case. They do it on TV all the time.
是的，但你知道，我想我们假装成医生，我们来探望[？玛丽莲·琼斯？]。那是个特殊病例。电视上总这么演。
I can flash my DCFS badge.
我可以出示我的儿童与家庭服务局（DCFS）徽章。
I was going to play like I worked for DCFS. I do work for DCFS.
我本来打算装作我在DCFS工作。我确实在DCFS工作。
Department of Children and Family Services.
儿童与家庭服务局。
State agency.
州政府机构。
So I was going to show my ID and said that I had to talk to her about her kids.
所以我本来打算出示我的证件，说我有事要跟她谈谈她孩子的事。
At 5:00 in the morning? I'm from DCFS, I got to talk to you about your kids at 5:00 in the morning.
凌晨5点？我是DCFS的，我凌晨5点得跟你谈谈你孩子的事。
Now see, I was the last one they picked up, so I didn't know anything about that.
你看，我是最后一个被接上的，所以我对那个一无所知。
And your reaction was?
那你当时什么反应？
I would not have agreed with that.
我不会同意那样的。
My [UNINTELLIGIBLE] out. I'm with DCFS legal. I need to have her sign some papers.
我的[听不清]出来了。我是DCFS法律部的。我需要让她签些文件。
She has high blood pressure and her sugar is up, so we don't want to excite her too much, but we want to give her that hen love.
她血压高而且血糖也高，所以我们不想让她太兴奋，但我们想给她那种“母鸡之爱”。
Well, not right now, Rosetta.
好吧，不是现在，罗塞塔。
And hen love.
还有“母鸡之爱”。
Give her a big hug and kiss.
给她一个大大的拥抱和亲吻。
The Hens. Most of them have known each other since they were teenagers, growing up in Inglewood on Chicago's south side. A couple joined the group when they were working with other hands at the switchboard at The Palmer House, a fancy Chicago Hotel. Nine women. And every March they take a big trip together or they throw a party. Like the dinner dance they threw for themselves and their families where everybody wore white and gold. Everybody.
“母鸡们”。她们大多数人从青少年时期就认识了，在芝加哥南区的英格尔伍德（Inglewood）一起长大。当她们在芝加哥高档的帕尔默酒店（The Palmer House）总机工作时，有几个加入了这个团体。一共九个女人。每年三月，她们都会一起大出游或者举办派对。就像她们为自己和家人举办的晚餐舞会，每个人都穿白色和金色的衣服。每个人。
This March, they took a tape recorder and drove from Chicago to a casino in Mississippi and back in three days. They visited a stray Hen who works down at the casino, Sally.
今年三月，她们带着录音机，从芝加哥开车去密西西比的赌场，三天内往返。她们探望了一只在赌场工作、落单的“母鸡”——萨莉（Sally）。
Three of the Hens-- Jewel, Tiny, and Lynn came into the studio to talk about trip and explain what the Hens are all about.
三只“母鸡”——朱厄尔、泰妮和琳来到演播室，讲述了这段旅程，并解释了“母鸡们”到底是做什么的。
In the South, they say that when it's a bunch of women that get together, a bunch of hens.
在南方，人们说当一群女人聚在一起时，就是一群“母鸡”。
Yeah, they say it in kind of a mean way.
是的，他们说这话时带点恶意。
Yeah, but we didn't take it as being means.
是的，但我们没觉得有什么恶意。
Hens to the Hilt.
“母鸡到极致”（Hens to the Hilt）。
Hilt. That was our original name.
“到极致”（Hilt）。那是我们最初的名字。
Because when we traveled, we only stayed at Hilton Hotels.
因为我们旅行时只住希尔顿（Hilton）酒店。
Well, hell, your husband said something about they ain't nothing but a bunch of hens.
好吧，该死，你丈夫说过她们不就是一群母鸡吗。
Bunch of hens. Now he did say that in a mean way.
一群母鸡。现在他这话确实说得带恶意。
In a very mean way.
非常带恶意。
And you guys will help each other out, like if somebody's out of work or if somebody needs some money. You guys will help out?
你们这些人会互相帮助，比如有人失业或需要钱的话？你们会帮忙？
We just did something like that recently. The last barbecue holiday. Valerie's son went out to the army, so we came together with our families and had a big barbecue. And at that barbecue we scraped together the little money that we had left to send him off to let him know we care. And sent him off with money in his pocket with all our phone numbers and our addresses. Have you got a letter yet?
我们最近确实刚做过这样的事。上一次烧烤节。瓦莱丽的儿子要去参军了，所以我们和家人聚在一起办了场大烧烤。在那次烧烤会上，我们凑了手头剩下的钱送他走，让他知道我们在乎他。送他走时口袋里装了钱，还有我们所有的电话号码和地址。你收到信了吗？
I haven't gotten anything yet.
我还没收到任何东西。
But we know he's doing fine. We try to do things like that to let each other's family know that we care.
但我们知道他过得很好。我们尽量做这类事情，让彼此的家庭知道我们在乎。
So when your kids were growing up, when your kids were coming up, would you have a lot of contact with each other, talking about all the stuff they were doing?
所以当你们的孩子长大的时候，当孩子开始懂事的时候，你们之间会有很多联系吗？讨论他们做的所有事情？
My kids basically stay with Jill and Barbara all the time.
我的孩子基本一直和吉尔（Jill）和芭芭拉住在一起。
We all had apartments next door to each other. When our babies were one and two. 101, 102, 103. I was 101, Tiny was 102, and Barbara was 103.
我们都住隔壁。当我们的宝宝才一两岁的时候。101，102，103。我住101，泰妮住102，芭芭拉住103。
There's a moment in the tape that you guys recorded on this last trip where really, literally everyone in the van is talking at the same time.
在上次旅行你们录下的磁带里，有一个时刻，真的，面包车里每个人都在同时说话。
And we understand each other.
而且我们听得懂对方。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[夹杂的声音]
Now let me get to just the facts of how this weekend worked. You guys left at 4:00 in the morning on Friday morning and then you drove for how many hours? Because you were heading from Illinois from Chicago through Tennessee, all the way to--
现在让我谈谈这个周末是怎么进行的。你们周五凌晨4点出发，开了多少小时车？因为你们从伊利诺伊州的芝加哥一路开到田纳西州，一直开到——
12. It took us 12 hours.
12小时。我们开了12小时。
You drove 12 straight hours more or less? And where did you--
你们几乎连续开了12小时？然后你们在哪儿——
Oh, we stopped. Oh, we stopped at a great place.
哦，我们停了一下。哦，我们在一个很棒的地方停下来。
And I got this great restaurant in Lambert's. Home of the throwed rolls. It's like, Jill, what you talking about? I said, you guys, they throw the rolls at you. People in the place throwing rolls and you have to catch them.
那是一家很棒的餐馆，叫兰伯特（Lambert's）。以抛掷面包卷闻名。我当时说，吉尔，你说什么呢？我说，伙计们，他们会把面包卷扔向你。店里的人都在扔面包卷，你得接住。
Throwing rolls at you?
扔面包卷向你？
Throwing dinner rolls at you. Hot dinner rolls at you.
扔热晚餐卷向你。
Catch, catch, catch!
接住，接住，接住！
Because their rolls are so good that they couldn't serve them fast enough. So one day the owner just threw one and that's how it started. So all you have to do is hold up your hand and they throw it and you catch it.
因为他们的面包卷太好吃了，他们供不应求。所以有一天店主就扔了一个，就这样开始了。所以你只要举起手，他们扔过来，你就接住。
Now there's a recording of this and somebody apparently is not doing a very good job doing the catching.
现在有段录音，显然有人接的时候做得不怎么好。
Me.
我。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
[听不清的短语]。
All right, so what's the name of this place for people listening on the radio--
好的，那么对于听广播的人来说，这家餐馆的名字是什么——
Lambert's.
兰伯特。
Lambert's and where is it?
兰伯特，它在哪儿？
At interstate 57 and 55 there's Lambert's.
在57号和55号州际公路旁就有兰伯特。
Every time we get together is not fun and games, but then when we get together the following time we laugh about it. Because the last time we went to Oakbrook that really wasn't fun.
每次我们聚在一起不都是玩游戏，但下次再聚时，我们会拿它开玩笑。因为上次我们去橡树溪（Oakbrook）的那次真的一点也不好玩。
Why? What happened?
为什么？发生了什么？
For years, Valerie has always so to speak, picked on Tony. Tony. You know because Tony is the slow one. She's very slow. You have to wait for her.
多年来，瓦莱丽一直，怎么说呢，在找托尼（Tony）的茬。托尼。你知道，因为托尼是那种反应慢的。她非常慢。你得等她。
Help her. She walks with a cane sometime.
帮帮她。她有时拄着拐杖走。
Yeah, you know, so she can't decide what she wants to put on. And so this particular night, Valerie just picked on Tony one too many times. It was about some pictures or something. So the next thing I know, Tony had jumped up out her chair and [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. It was like RoboCop. She said, whoomp, whoomp, whoomp.
是啊，你知道，她决定不了自己想穿什么。所以那天晚上，瓦莱丽又找了托尼一次茬。大概是关于照片什么的。所以下一刻我反应过来时，托尼已经从椅子上跳起来[听不清]。就像机械战警一样。她说，呜，呜，呜。
Coming over there to get Valerie.
冲过去找瓦莱丽。
Just stomps across the room.
就在屋子里跺脚。
No, Sally and I looked at each other. We said, oh, no. We ran. We left from there because I said I'm not-- we left.
不，萨莉和我面面相觑。我们说，哦，不。我们跑了。我们离开那儿了，因为我说我才不——我们离开了。
That's the closest to a couple hens fighting.
那是“母鸡打架”最接近的一次了。
But it wasn't funny at the time. But we get together now and we laugh about it.
但当时一点也不好笑。不过我们现在聚在一起都会拿它开玩笑。
There's a point where you guys are in the van and you got into this conversation about abortion that began when somebody was talking about these stories in the newspaper. And there came a point in that conversation, Tiny, where you said, we were such brave souls to have our kids when we did. Because most of you had your kids when you were teenagers.
在面包车里有一个点，你们讨论起了堕胎的话题，起因是有人在谈论报纸上的故事。泰妮，在谈话中的某个时刻，你说，我们那个时候生孩子真是太勇敢了。因为你们大多数人在十几岁时就有了孩子。
Right. We all did.
是的。我们都是。
And then Barbara says-- she's kind of off mike. You can barely hear it. She says, well not so brave. I was seven months pregnant before told my father.
然后芭芭拉说——她离麦克风有点远。你几乎听不清。她说，也不算太勇敢。我怀孕七个月才告诉父亲。
I never forget the look in daddy's face. Whoo! Boy I'm glad I made it through that!
我永远忘不了爸爸当时的表情。哇！天哪，真庆幸我熬过来了！
What did he do? What did he say?
他做了什么？他说了什么？
You know how daddy had that vein on his head that pops, and it started jumping. And he looked at me--
你知道爸爸额头上那根会跳的青筋吗，它开始跳了。他看着我——
That's scary.
那太可怕了。
And he said, whose is it?
他说，是谁的？
I said Robert's! Tell him real quick!
我说罗伯特的！快告诉他！
You know, momma worked at St. Luke Presbytarian Hospital. And she took me for her--
你知道，妈妈在圣路加长老会医院工作。她带我去她的——
We're not going to have the same amount of fun every time we get together because our lives are changing.
我们不可能每次聚在一起都有同样的乐趣，因为我们的生活在变化。
Like one time we sat around talking about getting old. We're realizing that, heck, we're getting older and there was health issues.
比如有一次我们坐着谈论变老。我们意识到，该死，我们正在变老，而且有健康问题。
This year we had a serious issue we faced. We faced Tiny's father dying.
今年我们面临了一个严重的问题。泰妮的父亲去世了。
But also, you knew him going back to when you were younger too.
但你认识他也追溯到你们更年轻的时候。
Yeah, Mr. [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. I was very scared of that man.
是啊，[听不清]先生。我当时很怕那个人。
So you arrive at the hotel Friday.
所以你们周五到达酒店。
A little before six.
六点前一点。
A little before six Friday. And describe the hotel.
周五六点前一点。描述一下酒店。
Beautiful.
漂亮。
It was beautiful.
它很漂亮。
It was like Vegas sitting in the middle of a cotton field.
它就像坐在棉田中央的拉斯维加斯。
Yes, it was.
是的，确实是。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[夹杂的声音]
Do your husbands have anything like this with their male friends?
你们的丈夫会和他们的男性朋友一起搞这种东西吗？
No.
不。
No?
没有？
We have tried to encourage it, but they never do. They're real supportive now. We really had to go through a lot. And they do get crazy. Like the closer we get to that departing time--
我们尝试鼓励过，但他们从来不搞。他们现在真的很支持。我们确实经历了很多。他们会发疯。比如越接近那个出发时间——
They come up with their little bitty things.
他们就会想出那些琐碎的小事。
Little things, little things that aggravate you. But my husband has really gotten used to it. I'm thinking he's really gotten tired of me because he's-- remember when all came to pick me up. He was just calm in the chair. And that's not like Dale. He's like, see you all. You all have a good time.
小事，惹你生气的小事。但我丈夫真的习惯了。我想他真的厌倦我了，因为他——记得她们来接我的时候吗。他只是平静地坐在椅子上。那不像戴尔。他就像是，祝你们玩得开心。
John was the one. Now this is my son. He calls me in the room. Ma, I want to pray with you. I said, OK, John. I just want to pray for your safe trip. I said, OK, John. And he's holding my hand and he's praying.
约翰是那个。现在这是我儿子。他叫我进屋。妈，我想和你一起祈祷。我说，好吧，约翰。我只想为你祈求旅途平安。我说，好吧，约翰。他握着我的手在祈祷。
That was so funny.
那太搞笑了。
And I'm like, OK, John. You know, five minutes later he's still praying. I'm like, OK, John. Amen. Bye.
我就像是，好的，约翰。你知道，五分钟后他还在祈祷。我就像是，好的，约翰。阿门。再见。
I got to get on my trip. My Hens are waiting for me.
我得去旅行了。我的“母鸡们”在等我。
I have to deal with John now.
我现在得应付约翰。
What would your husbands, what would they used to do? What'd they used to say when you were about to get to go on a trip.
你们的丈夫，以前他们会怎么做？你们要出发去旅行时，他们会怎么说？
When you coming back?
你什么时候回来？
Can we say this on the radio?
我们在广播里能说这个吗？
Now, my other relationships could not deal with the Hens and we had to break up.
现在，我其他的关系无法接受“母鸡们”，我们不得不分手。
We had to be lesbians.
我们不得不是女同性恋。
Seriously. Yes.
严肃地。是的。
Oh, we're a bunch of lesbians.
哦，我们是一群女同性恋。
And I broke up with--
我跟——分手了。
That's what they would say, you're a bunch of lesbians?
他们就是这么说的，你们是一群女同性恋？
They could not deal with the idea of women get together.
他们无法接受女性聚在一起的想法。
We're going to sleep together, you know? Because we have so many beds. Each room have a bed in it. We're going to sleep together. Somebody's going to sleep with me that weekend.
我们要睡在一起，你知道吗？因为我们有那么多床。每个房间里都有张床。那个周末我们要睡在一起。有人会和我睡。
But the men in your lives, they must have their friends who they hang with?
但你们生活中的男人们，他们肯定有朋友一起聚吧？
Yeah, they do. They do.
是的，他们有。他们有。
But they don't have the same kind of bond. You know, they got friends that they hang with.
但他们没有那种纽带。你知道，他们有一起聚的朋友。
I don't think men have the same kind of relationship that women have.
我不认为男人们有女人那样的关系。
Yeah, I think it's very much a women's thing. Definitely a women's thing.
是的，我认为这非常像是女性特有的事情。绝对是女性的事情。
I think it's very much a women's thing.
我认为这非常像是女性特有的事情。
When I get with the Hens, I'm me. I'm Tiny. You know, I don't have to be [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. I don't have to be wife. I don't have to be mother. I'm not sitting up there flirting with anybody where I got to be a sexy broad. I'm Tiny, naturally. And anything that comes to my mind I can say it. And they're going to say, oh, is that how you think about it? Well I think this way and I like that input. But it's a natural thing.
当我和“母鸡们”在一起时，我就是我自己。我是泰妮。你知道，我不需要是[听不清]。我不需要是妻子。我不需要是母亲。我不需要坐在那里和任何人调情，假装自己是个性感的荡妇。我就是泰妮，自然地。任何我脑子里闪过的想法我都可以说出来。她们会说，哦，你是这么想的吗？嗯，我这么想，我喜欢那个建议。但这是一种自然而然的事情。
Hey, my seatbelt is working--
嘿，我的安全带能用——
Everybody in here [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
这里的每个人[听不清短语]。
The Hens-- Tiny, Lynn and Jewel in the studio. Also, Barbara, Rosetta, Valerie, Sally, Tony and Jan. This next song is the song that they always play driving home from their trips when they have to return to their husbands and kids and real life.
“母鸡们”——泰妮、琳和朱厄尔在演播室。还有芭芭拉、罗塞塔、瓦莱丽、萨莉、托尼和简。下一首歌是她们每次旅行归家，不得不回到丈夫、孩子和现实生活中时，在车里总是播放的歌。
[MUSIC- "BACK TO LIFE" BY SOUL II SOUL]
[音乐- Soul II Soul的《Back to Life》]
Act Four, Taking Sisterhood One Step Further.
第四幕，将姐妹情谊更进一步。
If you ask Elizabeth Joseph, it was the only reasonable choice to marry a man who was already married to five women. She met her husband when she was a senior in college.
如果你问伊丽莎白·约瑟夫（Elizabeth Joseph），嫁给一个已经娶了五个妻子的男人是唯一的合理选择。她在大学四年级时遇到了她的丈夫。
Well, you look at somebody in my situation. I was almost 21 years old. I could either marry somebody my own age and take another 10 years and finish the job of raising him, his mother started. Or I could marry a proven failure and I practice divorce law. I know there's all kinds of wonderful excuses for divorce, but by definition it's a failure. Or I could have found myself somebody who had proven himself to be a good husband, but maybe I didn't want to marry a 65-year-old widower.
嗯，你看看我的情况。我快21岁了。我可以嫁给一个同龄人，再花10年时间完成他母亲开始的抚养工作。或者我可以嫁给一个公认的失败者，我是做离婚法的。我知道关于离婚有各种各样的美妙借口，但根据定义，这就是失败。或者我可以找一个证明自己是个好丈夫的人，但我可能不想嫁给一个65岁的鳏夫。
So in Alex, there was no gamble. He was demonstrably a good husband, demonstrably a good father. So there was little risk to the situation.
所以在亚历克斯（Alex）身上，没有赌博。他显然是个好丈夫，显然是个好父亲。所以这种情况几乎没有风险。
Elizabeth Joseph is as an attorney and now public affairs director of a radio station in Utah. We offer her story as part of our show as another example in the continuum of how to be a woman or a girl. She says that because she was in a polygamist marriage, she could do things like go off to law school and finish school and not have to worry who was taking care of the kids or her husband. There were other wives around for that.
伊丽莎白·约瑟夫是一位律师，现在是犹他州一家广播电台的公共事务主管。我们将她的故事作为节目的一部分，作为关于如何做女人或女孩的连续体中的另一个例子。她说，因为她是一夫多妻婚姻，她可以做些事，比如去法学院完成学业，而不必担心是谁在照顾孩子或丈夫。还有其他妻子在照顾这些事。
In short, she says, polygamy is the ultimate feminist lifestyle.
总之，她说，一夫多妻制是终极的女性主义生活方式。
It's having a man on your own terms. You know, he's in your bed. He's in your house at your invitation. The juggling act that so many women have to put on with respect to careers and family is so much relieved in our situation because there are so many of us to share those kinds of household duties and child rearing and husband taking care of. So I'm able to go to work with a guilt free heart and child never sees the inside of a daycare center or anything like that. They're home with people who care about them.
这是按照你自己的条件拥有一个男人。你知道，他应你的邀请在你的床上、在你的家里。许多女性在职业和家庭之间不得不进行的杂耍式努力，在我们的情况下减轻了许多，因为我们有很多人来分担那种家务和育儿、照顾丈夫的工作。所以我能带着无罪恶感的心去工作，孩子永远看不到日托中心的内部，诸如此类。他们和照顾他们的人在一起。
Now your husband has eight wives?
现在你有八个妻子？
Yes.
是的。
And how many of the wives actually stay home? Do all of them work? Do just some of them work?
有多少个妻子实际上待在家里？她们都工作吗？只有一些工作？
Yeah, we all work. We all work. About nine years ago three of us had babies all in the same year and there was one wife in particular that we really wanted to watch out for the kids while we were at work. And so we went to her and said how much is it going to take to get you to quit your job for a couple of years til the kids go to school? So she did that for us. Then she went back to work.
是的，我们都工作。我们都工作。大约九年前，我们三个同一年生了孩子，特别有一个妻子我们真的很想让她在上班时照看孩子。所以我们去找她，说要给多少钱你才愿意辞掉工作几年，直到孩子上学？所以她为我们做了这件事。然后她又回去工作了。
And when you say, how much would it take you, did the rest of you pay her?
当你问要多少钱时，你们其余的人付给她了吗？
Yeah, the three of us paid her.
是的，我们三个付给她。
Wow.
哇。
It was only fair, she was working hard.
这很公平，她工作很努力。
So when you first met your husband, had you been considering polygamy as an option?
所以当你第一次见到你丈夫时，你有考虑过一夫多妻制作为一种选择吗？
Oh, only very recently because a friend of his had proposed to me also. But no, I didn't even know it existed when I was in college until I met my husband and his friend. I had no idea anybody was doing it modernly. I was aware of the LDS history of the last century.
哦，那是非常近期的事，因为他的一个朋友也向我求婚了。但没有，我在大学时甚至不知道它的存在，直到我遇见我丈夫和他的朋友。我不知道有人在现代还这样做。我意识到了上个世纪的后期耶稣基督后期圣徒教会（LDS）的历史。
The Mormon church, the Latter Day Saints Church? And when you met him, he was already married to five women at that point, right?
摩门教，后期圣徒教会？当你见到他时，他当时已经娶了五个妻子，对吗？
Correct.
对。
How did a courtship happen? Like what actually happened?
求爱是怎么发生的？到底发生了什么？
Well, we were separated by a thousand miles. He proposed by letter. And I flew down and spent my spring break my senior year with him and his family. He had married two of my best friends from college. So I came I thought as much to see them as him. But I just needed to check out the situation. And I went home married.
嗯，我们相隔千里。他是通过信件求婚的。我飞过去，在他和他的家人那里度过了我大四的春假。他娶了我在大学里的两个好朋友。所以我去的时候，我想看她们和看他一样重要。但我只是需要审视一下情况。然后我结婚回家了。
What did your family say?
你的家人怎么说？
They were understandably upset. My dad was very educated, but a Montana cowboy and he told my brothers to get their rifles and they were coming after me.
他们理所当然地很不安。我爸爸受过良好的教育，但是个蒙大拿牛仔，他告诉我的兄弟们拿上猎枪，他们要来找我。
Wow.
哇。
My mother's a very educated, smart women and she was heartbroken, but she wasn't willing to give the association with her only daughter to maintain a point.
我母亲是一个受过良好教育、聪明的女人，她心碎了，但她不愿为了一个观点而放弃与她唯一女儿的联系。
Can I ask you to just explain kind of the practical terms of it? Like does everybody live in separate houses? Does everybody live in the same house? How often do you see Alex?
我能请你解释一下它实际的情况吗？比如每个人住分开的房子吗？每个人住同一个房子吗？你多久见一次亚历克斯？
I see Alex every day for sure. Structurally, I have a home that I share with another wife just because it's so huge. But Margaret has her own place, Beau has our own place, Joanna has her own place. But we're all right close together.
我每天肯定能见到亚历克斯。在结构上，我有一个与另一个妻子共享的家，仅仅是因为它太大了。但玛格丽特（Margaret）有自己的地方，博（Beau）有自己的地方，乔安娜（Joanna）有自己的地方。但我们都离得很近。
It's not like if he's at Diane and [? Don's ?] house, I walk right in the front door and make myself at home. I mean, we enjoy each other's company. Margaret likes to say that he's more fun when there's more than one of us just because that's his nature. And yeah, there's three of us that have anniversaries real close together and it's a longstanding tradition for the four of us to go out to dinner together near those anniversary. You know, the family spends a lot of time together. The kids are very fond of one another from the different mothers.
如果他在戴安（Diane）和[？唐（Don）？]家，并不是我能直接走前门进去把自己当做家。我的意思是，我们享受彼此的陪伴。玛格丽特喜欢说，当我们在场的人不止一个时，他更有趣，因为这就是他的天性。是的，我们有三个人的结婚纪念日非常接近，我们四个人在那些纪念日附近一起出去吃晚餐是一个由来已久的传统。你知道，家庭在一起花很多时间。孩子们非常喜欢不同母亲生出来的孩子。
So how many kids are there in the family?
所以家里有多少个孩子？
20. And I'd say about half are grown.
20个。我想大概有一半已经长大了。
And then, how often will he actually stay with you if I can ask you questions that personal.
然后，如果我能问你这么隐私的问题，他实际上多久和你待一次？
Yeah, we actually stay with him. He's got his own quarters. But over the years it's varied. When I was 20 I had one kind of sexual appetite and now that I'm in my-- I hate to say this-- mid 40s, it's a little different. But in talking to my monogamous friends, I have that kind of exchange with him as often or more often than they do. You know, roughly average once a week. It just depends.
是的，我们实际上和他待在一起。他有自己的居所。但这些年来情况各不相同。我20岁时有一种性欲，现在我——我讨厌这么说——40多岁了，情况有点不同。但在和我的单配偶朋友交谈时，我和他进行那种交流的频率和她们一样多，甚至更多。你知道，大约平均每周一次。这取决于情况。
I've heard Mormon men talk about polygamy and talking about the advantage of it as being this. They say that there's certain things that a woman looks to a man for in terms of wanting to talk about things and wanting to be close regarding certain kinds of issues and have a certain kind of close friendship that a lot of men just they don't talk that way. They don't relate to other people that way. And so one of the advantages of polygamy is that the women, the wives, can get that from the other wives.
我听说过摩门教男人谈论一夫多妻制，认为它的优势在于这。他们说，在某些关于想和人谈论事情、想在某些问题上亲近以及拥有某种亲密友谊方面，女性会向男人求助，而很多男人只是——他们不那样说话。他们不那样与人交往。所以一夫多妻制的优势之一是女性，妻子们，可以从其他妻子那里得到这种东西。
That's one of the huge advantages. That's a really nice thing. I mean, some of our funnest times have been when he's been like on a business trip and we'll get together and have a tequila party or something and just laugh our heads off. Just have a good time. Because the way the wives feel about one another is we're just extraordinarily proud of one another. We're extremely proud to be associated with one another. And we've had women come into the situation and look into it. And we didn't like them, and we got rid of them. We're women. We're good at it.
那是巨大的优势之一。那真是件好事。我的意思是，我们最有趣的时候是他出差时，我们会聚在一起喝龙舌兰酒什么的，笑得前仰后合。玩得很开心。因为妻子们对彼此的感觉是我们对彼此感到非常自豪。我们为能与彼此联系在一起感到非常自豪。而且有女性进入这种情况并进行审视。我们不喜欢她们，我们就把她们踢出去了。我们是女人。我们擅长这个。
Do you have some sort of veto power over whether a woman actually gets to marry in?
对于一个女人是否真正能嫁进来，你们有某种否决权吗？
It's de facto, OK? The rule is he'll marry whom he pleases. But he has learned over the years that if we don't like them, his relationship with them is going nowhere. So we've chased off our share.
那是事实上的，OK？规则是他会娶他高兴的人。但他多年来已经学会了，如果我们不喜欢她们，他与她们的关系是不会有结果的。所以我们已经赶走了一部分。
And do people get jealous? Do you get jealous?
人们会嫉妒吗？你会嫉妒吗？
Well, you know, us American girls are raised to be very insecure and jealous. Neither of which is a trait that you would want to embrace. So in the early years I think as with any marriage, it takes a while to feel your way and get that security established. And yeah, there were times when I'd go well, why-- gee, you know, I can see way he likes Margaret. She does that so well and I don't. But then after a while you go, yeah, but look what I do that Margaret doesn't. And he does that. That's his job is to give you that security that he loves you for what you are. And 25 years into this deal and we've sort of got it down pat. We're not too threatened at all.
嗯，你知道，我们美国女孩从小就很不安全且容易嫉妒。这两者都不是你想要拥有的特质。所以早年间我想就像任何婚姻一样，需要一点时间去摸索和建立安全感。是的，曾经有几次我会想，好吧，哎呀，你知道，我能看出为什么他喜欢玛格丽特。她那方面做得很好，而我做不好。但后来你就会想，是的，但看看我做的事玛格丽特没做。他就是那样。这是他的工作，给你那种安全感，即他爱你本来的样子。在这段关系25年后，我们已经把它摸透了。我们根本不感到太大的威胁。
Is this something that you think should be widely recommended to people? Or do you feel like that you are just in a special situation with a special man and it's not applicable to other people's lives?
你认为这应该广泛推荐给人们吗？或者你觉得你只是处在一个有特殊男人的特殊情况中，它不适用于其他人的生活？
It's only a certain kind of people. For example, I had a son who he had a family. And I have a son. But anyway, a girl came to him who'd grown up in our community and she said what I said. You're obviously a good father and husband. Can I marry you? And he really liked this girl. But he was blown away. He goes, I don't know if I can do this. And of course I knew him very well, my son. I said, Stewart, you're one of the few guys I think can. And he lasted like two months.
这只适用于特定类型的人。例如，我有一个儿子，他有一个家庭。我有一个儿子。但不管怎样，一个在我们社区长大的女孩来到他面前，她说了我曾经说的话。你显然是个好父亲和丈夫。我可以嫁给你吗？他真的很喜欢这个女孩。但他被震撼了。他说，我不知道我能不能做到。我当然非常了解他，我的儿子。我说，斯图尔特（Stewart），你是我认为少数几个能做到的男人之一。他只坚持了大约两个月。
And why do you think it didn't work for him?
你为什么认为这对他不起作用？
Well, usually two wives is very difficult. You really need a third to balance it out. But usually, the most common scenario is the two women will gang up on the guy.
嗯，通常两个妻子是非常困难的。你真的需要第三个来平衡它。但通常，最常见的情况是两个女人会联手对付这个男人。
But you're thinking like 1 out of 10 men that you know could do it or like it's more m 1 out a 100?
但你认为是你认识的男人中大概十分之一能做到，还是更像是百分之一？
More like 1 out of 1,000, if not 10,000.
更像是千分之一，甚至万分之一。
Wow.
哇。
It's not easy. That's why most of his boys will tell you they wouldn't entertain it because they know how difficult it is. Because they watch their dad do it.
这不容易。这就是为什么他大多数的儿子会告诉你他们不会考虑这样做，因为他们知道这有多难。因为他们看着他们的父亲这样做。
And the main difficulty is just keeping everybody satisfied and happy?
主要的困难只是让每个人都感到满意和快乐吗？
Well, yeah. You got to be way smart. Like he says, how would you like eight women working your inventory 24 hours a day we? And we do. We do. We're strong willed, independent, say what we think.
嗯，是的。你得非常聪明。就像他说的，如果你有八个女人24小时盯着你的库存，你会感觉如何？我们确实这样。我们意志坚强、独立，想到什么就说什么。
I haven't met anybody that could do what Alex has done. I've met polygamists, long-term polygamists, who I admire and respect for what they've done. But in terms of demonstration, it doesn't come anything close to his family.
我还没遇到过能做亚历克斯所做之事的人。我遇到过我钦佩和尊重他们所作所为的一夫多妻者，长期的那种。但从示范的角度来看，没有什么能比得上他的家庭。
Elizabeth Joseph in Utah.
犹他州的伊丽莎白·约瑟夫。
Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org where you can listen to our programs for absolutely free or buy CDs of them. Or you know you can download today's program in our archives at audible.com/thisamericanlife.
我们的网站，www.thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以绝对免费地收听我们的节目或购买它们的CD。或者，你知道你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife的档案中下载今天的节目。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[赞助字幕]
WBEZ management oversight from Mr. Torey Malatia who says that from now on he wants to be called-
WBEZ的管理监督人托瑞·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生说，从现在起他希望被称呼为——
Ghetto hoochie mama.
贫民窟浪荡女。
Or perhaps you would prefer--
或者也许你更喜欢——
Booty house girl.
翘臀舞派对女孩。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of this American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带回更多美国生活的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。